it is nick knighter the number 15
prospect in the marlin system according
to baseball america this is his third
career start and as holly noted the
first here at lone depot park
there's anthony santander that's the guy
we watched a lot last year a rope into
center field for a base hit
flip over oh what happened there
santander came in awkward on the base
as you go back in he lunges with the
left foot yep you see that ankle roll to
the outside
and that's what you see sometimes you
know when you go back in with your feet
right on the edge of that bag and he
rolled it to the outside part you can
look at it right there well if you've
ever done that that hurts brandon hyde
and brian evil help him into the dugout
in the count two strikes to mancini
little looper coming hard in left field
and he won't get there that was
dickerson and the orioles have him
loaded
that's what you need when you're
scuffling a little a couple of goals to
fall in base is loaded for michael
franco one down oriole's trying to jump
out early
little roller to short only one play
that's first base
and franco gets another rbi rbi number
15 for him the orioles lead it one
nothing from the belt ready with the 1-1
hit hard that's a fair ball missed the
first time not this time and rio ruiz
knocks in two with a double into the
right field corner and the orioles go up
three nothing
there's your big base hit with runners
in scoring position and two out this
will be his 30th pitch of the first
inning and
look what i found
flips it to first but the orioles get
three
marlins will come to the plate against
harvey when we come back of course
they'll take their swings off of matt
harvey making his fourth start he has
been really good at throwing strikes 12
punch outs only three walks
like miggy down the line should be extra
bases
he's around first
ball is still lost in the corner and
he's going to third
the throw is late and in there safely is
miguel rojas
maybe one guy can step up i don't know
great swing two-seam fastball splits the
plate stays inside and shoots it down
the right field line aguilera with an
11-game hit streak
and down he goes strike three
the first strikeout for matt harvey it's
a good one leaves that runner stranded
at third two down
that's a hot shot past franco and into
left field it's a base hit and it's an
rbi for adam duvall duvall got it done
his 12th run batted in and the marlins
make it a 3-1 game
that's hit hard right field back deep
hayes racing back to the wall
austin hayes welcome back
what a catch how about you austin hayes
and welcome back to an oriole uniform
this is a game saver hayes all the way
up against the wall to get the orioles
off the field orioles lead 3-1
knighter gets a ground ball off the bat
of mullins right to
jazz chisholm
gets the strikeout and works one two
three second head to the oriole third
inning it'll be mancini against young
nick nadar count is full
that's it well
racing way back and forget about it it's
gone trey mancini
out of the house number four for trey
and the orioles go up four to one
does five for your last six
is that hot that's pretty good that's
hot
and this was a big ball here
high fives all around the oriole dugout
the pitch is swung on and missed
oh that's it well
right field and back and gone freddie
galvez second home run of the inning oh
just a shot by freddie galvez number two
for freddie galvez and run number five
for the orioles
harvey ahead two strikes
and he got him two down in the marlins
third
two on two out
and he got him chased upstairs out of
the zone
harvey with back-to-back strikeouts
he's hit a fly ball to center field is
only at bat
there's a base hit in the center field
so a two out single from austin hayes
the orioles have had base runners in
every inning but the second
stewart
drive
steep left center way back
and it's off the wall around third is
hayes he will score
and dj stewart with an rbi double and
the orioles tack on another run at 6-1
boy talk about being on time huh harvey
back to work here with a five-run lead
jorge alfaro to lead things off grounds
one right side
and bobbled by
ruiz
so alfaro on base again the concern
turns toward alfaro who has been dealing
with
or had been dealing with that hamstring
tightness
and having to hustle down the line he
might be stretching that out i think
he's uncomfortable you see him pull up
just a little bit as he crosses the bag
that's gonna be it
take him
so wallach will replace alfaro
2-2 on the way
and he got him
[Applause]
so the double play followed by the
strikeout marlins done in the fourth
orioles on top 6-1
and now this one into right field to
base it
came up empty going a left so he'll try
right for his first hit tonight
ground ball left side galvez doesn't
have a play and miggy has himself
another hit a three for three night for
miguel rojas
slowly hit left side franco up with it
they'll make the play over to first
dickerson comes in to score duvall's got
both marlon's rbis tonight it is six to
two
harvey delivers and a ground ball up the
middle galvez can't get to it mickey
around third he's going to score and
brian anderson comes through with an rbi
single that's got to feel good marlins
continue to chip away it's now six to
three yes sir getting it done
bounce to short galvez there's the force
out they get it this time marlins
retired they do get a couple of runs
orioles still on top 6-3
they've turned it over to the bullpen
with a lead
and wallach lines a base hit into center
field
[Applause]
full full count pitch is
just low and in
for ball four armstrong won at that one
31st
three hit game for rojas
he's got seven four hit games
a knock here makes this a little bit
more interesting live drive base hit
interesting it will get
brinson had to hold up not sure if
galvest was going to make the play so at
station to station baseball rojas is
four for four
and the marlins are down six to four and
that's the eighth time in his career
he's been able to put together a four
hit game
and aguilar out to center field mullins
backs up
just a couple of steps and then comes in
that'll be deep enough to score the run
birdie up to third and it's six to five
on the sac fly
and he got him
through the slider by him
wheel with a two run double in the first
inning
it's that hard that's a fair ball down
the right field corner
ruris around first
and he'll go on standing at second with
a two base hit
second double of the game for rio
bounced into left field that's a base
hit
that'll score a run give freddie galvez
an rbi his second of the game and the
orioles on top 7-5
mancini pops one up
near the
dugout
[Applause]
the snow cone catch for out number two
cesar valdez quick pitch and he got him
so three strikeouts and four hitters and
the orioles win it seven to five pretty
good relief pitching ben i'd say so